tag zusammen herzlich willkommen zur zdf
heute live eure ihren live stream zu
aktuellen diskussion und ereignissen die
pandemie geht eigentlich wahrscheinlich
allen von uns richtig auf die nerven
manchen tatsächlich so sehr dass sie in
depressionen und den angststörungen
verfallen psychische probleme treten
immer häufiger auf warnen die diversen
berufsverbände der psychotherapeuten und
psychiater innen und die sagen sie
kommen kaum mehr hinterher den
betroffenen zu helfen die praxen sind
übervoll die wartelisten sind ellenlang
wir wollen heute darüber reden was die
korona krisen mit unserer psyche macht
warum es so schwierig ist den
betroffenen die hilfe zukommen zu lassen
die sie brauchen und wir werden auch
darüber sprechen die man sich selber
helfen kann trotzdem hier jetzt auch
noch mal deutlich eine träger warnung
von meiner seite wir sprechen hier eben
über psychische probleme und wenn er
oder sie mit solchen zu kämpfen habt
vielleicht sogar mit suizidgedanken dann
bitte sucht euch hilfe wir werden auch
hier darüber sprechen wo es noch hilfe
gibt es ganz akute hilfe an dem man sich
wenden kann und zwar werden wir heute
darüber sprechen mit doktor sabine
köhler vorsitzende des berufsverbandes
deutscher nervenärzte psychiaterin und
psychotherapeutin in jena und mit
matthias münch fahrzeuglackierer
amateurfußball trainer und betroffener
der sehr offen über seine psychischen
probleme spricht
ich sage schon mal an beide einen
schönen guten abend schön dass sie dabei
sind
so jetzt haben wir ja alles da
man kann das noch nicht hören aber
werden mit ihnen gleich sprechen fragen
und kommentare zum thema wenn er oder
sie betroffen seid wenn ihr eine frage
habt wenn ihr ja eine einschätzung haben
wir eine eigene geschichte bitte sehr
gerne in die dafür vorgesehenen
kommentarspalten oder per mail wie immer
an zdf heute.de zdf.de und bevor wir
jetzt starten mit der diskussion gibt
uns julia viegener einmal einen
überblick über die aktuelle lage in den
praxen
wer in deutschland krank wird und hilfe
braucht muss erstmal warten
eine umfrage der deutschen
psychotherapeutenvereinigung ergab nur
die wenigsten erhalten einen
behandlungsplatz innerhalb von drei
monaten durchschnittlich dauert es ein
halbes jahr und mehr als ein drittel der
betroffenen wartet sogar noch länger
therapieplätze sind schon länger
mangelware
die wartezeiten seit jahren ein problem
für menschen in der krise ist das eine
zumutung
pro jahr haben rund 28 prozent der
erwachsenen mit einer psychischen
erkrankung zu kämpfen
die meisten leiden an angststörungen
depressionen und erkrankungen durch den
konsum von alkohol und medikamenten
corona hat die lage verschärft praxen
berichten anfang dieses jahres von 40
prozent mehr anfragen als zu beginn des
jahres 2020
sie haben wir fangen an in jena mit dr
sabine köhler vorsitzende des
berufsverbandes deutscher nervenärzte
psychiaterin und psychotherapeutin
kommen sie noch hinterher
mit ihrer arbeit ja das ist eine
berechtigte frage das wird im moment
immer schwieriger unsere praxen sind
sehr sehr voll wir haben einen ansturm
an patienten vor corona schon gehabt die
inanspruchnahme von fachärztlicher
psychiatrischer und
psychotherapeutischer leistung ist
gewachsen mit der in stigmatisierung
dieser themen depression angststörungen
usw
seit corona haben wir einen sehr sehr
großen anstieg der inanspruchnahme und
die patienten die zu uns kommen sind
deutlich kränker die haben einen höheren
leidensdruck die haben viel mehr
probleme haben auch viel mehr soziale
probleme jetzt aktuell bekommen und das
ist wirklich schwer zu schaffen aktuell
dh die lage war vorher schon angespannt
weil immer mehr menschen ihre praxen
gekommen sind entstigmatisierung sagen
das hier ist ja eigentlich was gutes
dass menschen sich um ihre psyche
kümmern aber der bedarf ist so groß dass
sie nicht mehr hinterherkommen wie viele
leute mussten sie dann schon vertrösten
oder machen sie jetzt überstunden als
wir machen zum einen tatsächlich
überstunden wir arbeiten das ist so die
rückmeldung meiner kollegen aus dem
gesamten bundesgebiet im durchschnitt
eine stunde am tag länger die mittags
so sind eingekürzt wir haben also höhere
fallzahlen in den großen versorger
facharztpraxen das heißt die praxen die
eben nicht schwerpunktmäßig
psychotherapeutisch arbeiten sondern die
diagnostik und akutversorgung von
menschen die hilfe suchen anbieten und
wir haben die taktung erhöht die der
durchlauf ist einfach viel schneller wir
haben dann natürlich pro patient weniger
zeit ja also es geht zum einen auf die
zeit des einzelnen hilfesuchenden der
kommt und der vielleicht erwartet dass
er bei uns eine stunde gespräch bekommt
die ja auch bekommt wenn es dringend
notwendig ist aber es geht vor allen
dingen auf die zeit die der arzt auch
für sich verwendet und zur reflexion der
eigenen tätigkeit oder der freizeit
das muss man schon sagen das ist aktuell
gelebte realität in den facharztpraxen
das würde ich kaum noch etwas nach das
ist ihnen also wie geht es ihnen damit
wir hören ja aus den krankenhäusern doch
viel viele leidende pflegerinnen und
pfleger und ärzte die sagen wir können
nicht mehr wie ist das bei ihnen und
ihren kolleginnen
das ist ähnlich also wir sind hoch
beansprucht wir haben es gelernt in
unserer ausbildung auch auf uns selbst
zu achten und auf die eigene psyche
hygiene zu achten
wir haben gelernt auch
entspannungstechniken und freizeit
beachtung und selbstmanagement so zu
betreiben dass wir gesundbleiben
aber es fällt im moment schwer und
kostet mehr mühe als das vor corona der
fall war
wenn sie jetzt sagen es kommen mehr
menschen zu ihnen können sie das
vielleicht mal ein bisschen
konkretisieren mit mit welchen problemen
kommen die menschen tatsächlich konkret
hin in die praxen
es ist genau das eingetreten was bei der
rückwärtigen betrachtung andere
epidemien oder pandemien schon
festgestellt worden ist es kommen
patienten die unter den sozialen
unsicherheiten aktuell leiden und die
dann symptome psychischer erkrankungen
störungen ausbilden ängste allgemeine
ängste zukunftsängste ängste wie die
versorgung des eigenen der eigenen
bedürfnisse und der angehörigen
vonstatten geht wie sie die situation
meistern in der sie sich befinden die
soziale unsicherheit meistern und die
bekommen also die diagnose einer
angststörung oder auch depressive
erkrankungen treten auf sie hatten sehr
vorhin im teaser gezeigt auch süchte
treten vermehrt auf also alkohol und
medikamentenabhängigkeit sehen wir
häufiger in den praxen als das von
corona der fall war
jetzt haben wir hier viele
kommentatorinnen die quasi sagen es ist
nichts corona es ist nicht der das virus
sondern es sind die maßnahmen die uns
krank machen und es gibt tatsächlich
auch einige die sagen maßnahmen weg dann
geht es wieder gut ist es aus ihrer
sicht so einfach ich sehe tatsächlich
auch patienten die direkten kontakt mit
corona hatten zum einen weil sie selber
betroffen waren oder angehörige haben
die betroffen gewesen sind ich habe
patienten viele patienten die auch
todesfälle zu beklagen haben ich sehe
auch menschen die in den pflegeheimen
oder auf den intensivstationen tätig
sind wo corona eingeschlagen ist und
eine eine eine welle der der anstrengung
und und des schreckens hinter sich her
gezogen hat ich glaube ganz sicher wenn
wir diese maßnahmen nicht einhalten dass
wir mit größeren gesundheitlichen sorgen
zu kämpfen haben und es ist durchaus so
dass auch diese maßnahmen ängste
auslösen aber die krankheit an sich löst
ja ängste aus und löst unsicherheit aus
und hinterlässt auch folgen bei den
menschen die beispielsweise seit einem
jahr oder seit mehr als einem jahr auf
intensivstation unter vollschutz corona
patienten betreuen müssen
die schwer krank sind die über monate
beatmet sind teilweise und die sterben
ja und wo menschen auch entscheidungen
müsse ist das jetzt ein patient der
beatmet werden muss und kann oder wird
er nicht beatmet riskieren wir da das
also eine art insuffizienz der tod
eintritt oder machen wir ja maximal
medizin
das sind die entscheidungen die auf die
hat uns ärzte in so einer dimension
niemand vorbereiten können
gott sei dank also die meisten von uns
sind auf solche situationen nicht
vorbereitet auch auf den
intensivstationen und notaufnahmen nicht
das heißt wenn man jetzt mal ganz platt
sagt man fährt die maßnahmen runter man
lässt das virus laufen und hoffe es ist
irgendwie gut geht dann hat man
vielleicht weniger menschen die mit
depressionen und angststörungen kommen
weil sie nicht mehr sie isoliert leben
oder weil sie angst um ihren job haben
dafür hatten wir mehr leute die angst um
ihr leben haben oder die mit trauer und
mit verlusten zu kämpfen haben
also wird die den vergleich zu ländern
die nicht so strikte maßnahmen
eingeführt haben wie das in deutschland
der fall gewesen ist wenn man schweden
denken beispielsweise mittlerweile sind
die schweden aufgrund der desinfektions
geschehens und der erkrankungswelle im
land ja auch dazu übergegangen maßnahmen
zu ergreifen die beschränkten sich
auswirken führt für den bürger insofern
müsste man da vielleicht eine
epidemiologische oder kollegen aus den
also ein virologen ja wie sich das
auswirken würde wenn wir die maßnahmen
seien lassen würden
aber der schrecken der erkrankung wird
genau dieselben oder noch stärkere
psychische symptome nach sich ziehen wie
das im moment die scheinbare belastungen
durch die beschränkende maßnahmen tut
hier hat gibt es auch kommentatoren die
sagen diese auswirkungen der korona
maßnahmen auf die psyche wird nicht
genug mit einberechnet ist das in ihren
augen auch so ja also ich sehe dass die
welle die untersuchungen die wir aus der
vergangenheit kennen zeigen dass nach
einer epidemie dann diese welle an
psychosozialen und
dann auch psychischen beschwerden quasi
anfängt aufzulaufen nun haben wir jetzt
die dritte corona welle und sind quasi
in einer mittlerweile schon im vollen
gange seinen post co virtuelle aber wir
sind auch im moment noch in der kurve
quelle in der nächsten kurve quelle drin
das heißt die wellen überlagern sich und
es kommt zu einer zunahme an psychischen
ein psychischer krankheitslast und das
wird aktuell auch in der öffentlichen
diskussion und in der berücksichtigung
im politischen umfeld noch nicht
entsprechend gesehen im moment sind wir
alle mit impfungen mit restriktionen mit
schulen beschäftigt das ist das läuft
durch die öffentlichkeit inwieweit die
psychische gesundheit da betroffen ist
oder auch die neurologische oder oder
psychologische gesundheit denn cupid
infektionen hinterlassen folgen auch ja
in der summe also somatische das wird
kaum gesprochen also allenfalls die die
lungenkrankheiten da blickt man noch
rein weil einen das vielleicht plausibel
erscheint als laien dass man nach einer
beatmung vielleicht doch mehr
lungenprobleme hat aber das auch nicht
bad mit der patientin folgeerkrankung
haben können wie beispielsweise
psychische erkrankungen das wird noch zu
wenig berücksichtigt und das versuchen
wir heute zu ändern aber für viele
menschen ist es ja schon schwierig
tatsächlich über ihre psychischen
probleme oder herausforderungen zu
sprechen und dann nach hilfe zu suchen
ist dann schon die erste große hürde die
genommen werden muss ich freue mich
deswegen sehr dass wir heute einen gast
bei uns haben der beides geschafft hat
und der auch hilfe bekommen hat und
bereit ist darüber zu sprechen
juli afp nach stellten uns vor
mathias münch fußballtrainer ehemann
familienvater letztes jahr wirbelt die
korona pandemie sein leben durcheinander
erst kurzarbeit dann der jobverlust
irgendwann ist es ihm zuviel
schlafstörung und übelkeit erbrechen
man hat so eine innere leere gehabt man
wusste nicht mehr was man am besten
machen soll
man hat sich selbst zurückgezogen auch
aus dem freundeskreis und dann hat
schmerz geträumt dass ich mich
vorzugsweise und da wusste ich jetzt
geht's nicht mehr um ihn daraufhin zum
arzt die diagnose depression und
angststörungen sieben wochen verbringt
mathias münch in dieser klinik im
rheinhessischen alzey und lernt nun in
einer therapie dauerhaft mit angst und
stress umzugehen
es liegt in meiner hand weil die
medikamente alleine machen das nicht sie
unterstützen nur ich muss jetzt schauen
wo sind meine grinsen bis wohin kann ich
gehen was mag ist anders in sozialen
netzwerken zeigt der 33 jährige offen
was er über sich und seine krankheit
lernt und so will er auch andere
ermutigen sich helfen zu lassen
und da ist es zugeschaltet matthias
nicht schön dass die heute da sind wie
schwer war das für sie darüber so offen
zu reden dass sie hilfe brauchen
am anfang war es natürlich für mich sehr
schwer zu wissen auch wie reagieren die
freunde darauf das ganze umfeld
es hat schon eine weile gedauert bis ich
da offen drüber reden konnte wie sind
sie zu dem entschluss gekommen dass es
besser ist für sie darüber zu reden gab
es da auch so ein impuls von von ihrem
therapeuten oder war das so aus ihnen
heraus das war ganz allein von mir
heraus gekommen da ich ja auch
fußballtrainer bin und ist auch mit
meinen jungs gesprochen habe und die das
alles so super aufgenommen habe ich
gemerkt habe dass wir das sehr gut tat
daraufhin habe ich das dann auch
öffentlich gemacht und was war so dass
das feedback also gab's dann auch andere
die gesagt haben ja danke dass du es mal
anspricht bei mir geht es genauso ich
kann momentan wirklich nur positiv
darüber reden auch in den
zahl netzwerken wird viel darüber
gesprochen auch auf meiner seite wird
viel geschrieben die leute bedanken sich
teilweise von mir dass ich so auch und
damit umgehe
und das ist auch sehr schön forderte
köhler sie haben schon gesagt es gibt
eine entstigmatisierung also es wird
immer normaler darüber zu reden über
psychische probleme und erkrankungen
trotzdem scheint es aber immer noch eine
hürde zu sein
für viele die hilfe zu suchen wie auch
merken sie dass menschen zu ihnen
vielleicht auch zu spät kommen ja häufig
merke ich dass wenn patienten
beispielsweise verschiedene andere
interventionen selber probiert haben die
versuchen natürlich erstmal weniger
stigmatisierende dinge zu versuchen die
belesen sich im internet heutzutage und
versuchen da in gruppen hilfe zu
bekommen die in denen sie weniger
sichtbar sind also wo sie quasi anonym
bleiben können das passiert schon
relativ häufig vor allen dingen bei den
jungen leuten und wir sehen viele ältere
leute die dann mit von somatischen
erkrankungen beim arzt vorstellig werden
wo aber gar keine somatische erkrankung
gefunden werden kann und die dann über
den hausarzt quasi zu uns überwiesen
werden wenn alles somatische
ausgeschlossen werden automatisch heißt
also menschen kommen nach bauchschmerzen
körperlicher bauchschmerzen
kopfschmerzen übelkeit hatte damit war
ihnen das von anfang an klar dass sie
ihr übelkeit ihre schlafstörungen was
mit ihrer psyche zu tun haben oder haben
sie erst mal gesagt hat fertig gegessen
ja natürlich ich hab es gedacht hätten
den wagen jetta oder durch den ganzen
stress der momentan da war dass es davon
kam am anfang habe ich überhaupt nicht
an die ziele gedacht und wie schwierig
war das dann für sie tatsächlich auch
hilfe zu bekommen also wie wie tätig
mussten sie da werden
bei mir ging es eigentlich relativ
schnell
ich bin zum haushalts gegangen habe ihm
eine problematik erzählt auch von meinem
traum
und da war dann schnell klar dass ich
eine selbst anweisung für die fachklinik
bekommen habe ist das normal frau dr
köhler dass das so fix geht also bei
akuter gefahr wie das hier gerade
berichtet worden ist ist das ganz normal
dafür haben wir eigentlich
deutschlandweit versorgung schicken die
dann auch verpflichtet sind jemanden der
so akut krank ist wie dieses health
berichtet hat also mit suizidalen
gedanken mit dem impuls sich etwas
anzutun sich das leben zu nehmen
dann ist es in vielen fällen die aller
aller beste und schnellste lösung
jemanden in die klinik einzuweisen
wenngleich das natürlich auch eine
krankheitssituation ist die nicht so
häufig ist gott sei dank
in vielen fällen ist ja eine stationäre
behandlung gar nicht erforderlich
sondern wir können eine depressive
erkrankung eine angsterkrankung sehr gut
ambulant behandeln ohne so eine wirklich
einschneidende erfahrung dann stationär
zu sein von der familie fern zu sein aus
dem lebensrhythmus genommen zu werden
es gibt jetzt hierher münchen sehr viel
respekt für sie und auch dank zum
beispiel von tp da sagt sie haben die
stärke ihr leid nicht nur anzuschauen
sondern es auch offen zu kommunizieren
ich kann von ihnen etwas lernen das
freut uns glaube ich hier in der runde
es gibt aber auch jetzt die wortmeldung
von roberta hier auf facebook die
schreibt interessiert leider ganz wenige
menschen es wird immer wieder
beantwortet dass die menschen und
kindern krieg viel schlimmeres erlebt
haben und deswegen sollten den nicht
jammern man darf nichts sagen oder wird
gleich wo das wird leicht gesagt dass
wir eine verwöhnte gesellschaft sind was
würden sie denn beantworten herr münch
auf so eine wortmeldung das ist auch
schon mal gehört gesagt noch gar nicht
und eigentlich auch gar nicht dass ich
darauf antworten würde jetzt auf die
schnelle weil das jetzt von jetzt auf
gleich eine antwort zu geben
nicht gut dann finde ich gebe weiter an
frau dr köhler wie empfinden sie das
kann man so dieses leid oder diese
krisen miteinander wirklich gut
vergleichen
also entweder in seiner antwort wenn man
sie bekommt von von menschen
da schwingt ja schon ganz viel abwehr
mit also die möchten sich mit dem thema
möglichst nicht beschäftigen und lehrern
das mit so einer aggressiven form
darüber können wir jetzt gar nicht reden
das war früher alles viel schlimmer das
wären menschen ja mit seiner form ab das
heißt sie sind da nicht bereit darüber
sich auszutauschen sich gedanken zu
machen und sich mit dem individuellen
leid des gegenübers zu beschäftigen
da kann man der tat wenig antworten
darauf sondern man soll sich an das
gespräch an stellen suchen wo man meine
offenheit erfährt und die gibt es ja
durchaus auch also es gibt ja auch
gruppen oder oder blogs die sich damit
beschäftigen also wie erwünscht das jahr
initiiert hat wird seine seite möglich
da austauschen kann ich diese positiven
erfahrungen die erde bekommen also
gemacht machen durfte machen ein mehr
auch mut das ist eine offenheit in der
gesellschaft gibt sich mit diesen themen
auseinanderzusetzen
herr münchen sind ja auch fußballtrainer
haben da wahrscheinlich auch mit kindern
und jugendlichen zu tun wie nehmen sie
das wahr wie geht es denen dann gerade
auch jetzt wo sie ließen sich nicht mehr
auf dem fußballplatz ausdrucken können
ja ich bin also für die herren zuständig
da kriege ich natürlich viel leid mit
dass die jungs entsteht der auswahl
achten platz das den die decke und kopf
hält das alles umsonst war was in den
letzten jahr anders trainiert wurde es
ganz ganz schwer und an die zeit unter
aufsicht spalt dass es da wieder losgeht
können sie die noch motivieren schaffen
sie das es ist teilweise schwierig
manche lassen sich noch motivieren
fehler wenn nicht mehr was ich auch eine
auf einer seite gut verstehen kann weil
es geht jetzt eineinhalb jahre fußball
wurde zweimal unterbrochen dann wieder
neu angefangen wieder unterbrochen
das ist schwierig die motivation
hochzuhalten nehmen sie das wahr frau
backt oder was kriegen sie von ihren ja
auch fachärztin für kinder- und
jugendpsychiatrie zurückgespielt
die
also die lang dauernde ausnahme
situation ist schon schwierig weil ich
sehe natürlich auch immer wieder die
hoffnung bei den leuten das ist jetzt
nun mal das leichter wird das fehler
dass es wieder möglichkeiten gibt sich
zu treffen oder aktiv zu sein aber
mittlerweile ist natürlich auch eine
gewisse resignation eingetreten diese
vorstellungen von vor einem jahr dass
das quasi nach dem sommer vorbei ist
oder dass das im nächsten jahr alles
besser wird ist ja nicht eingetreten
sondern wir haben also eine zunahme
restriktionen und einer eskalation der
infektions situation in der ganzen welt
erlebt und das macht schon große sorgen
lust sind leicht man sagen muss die
aktuelle impfkampagnen die es gibt und
die letzte war seit letzter woche kann
in denen haus und fachärztlichen praxen
geimpft werden das ist wie so eine welle
an zuversicht die über die leute
schlafen wenn wir leute in den patienten
anrufen und sagen sie haben einen
impftermin kommen sie vorbei und sie
dürfen zum hausarzt gehen dass das löst
natürlich so viel freude und zuversicht
aus wie wir uns das schon lange
gewünscht haben also wir haben sie sind
ein kleines wunder dass dass dieser
impfstoff so schnell zur verfügung
gestanden hat wenn man ein anderer
epidemien denkt oder an die hiv
infektionen als die entdeckt wurde da
gibt es bis heute keinen schutz davor
außer kondome außer konto mit der klage
keine keine impfung oder es wurde ja
auch lange sofort wird aber da ist man
ja nicht erfolgreich gewesen und gegen
dieses garstige virus gibt es jetzt
schon eine impfung sagt toll was können
sie denn menschen wie hermann straten
oder auch eltern wenn sie es beobachten
dass die kinder immer depressiver werden
immer weniger zu motivieren sind was
kann man da machen das kann herr münch
quasi auch mit mit seinen jungs und
mädels machen also dass kontakt halten
das empfehlen wir sehr also auch den
patienten beispielsweise die
sehr darunter leiden dass sie in ihren
gruppen in ihren in ihren aktivitäten
erheblich eingeschränkt sind
da versuchen wir die ressourcen die es
gibt zu identifizieren telefonate
videoanrufe skype konferenzen sowie das
jetzt machen oder das ich rassen eins zu
eins treffen im freien gemeinsame
spaziergänge sowas in den alltag zu
etablieren die tag zu strukturieren
nicht sich einzumauern in der wohnung
sondern wenn es erlaubt ist wenn man
nicht unter quarantäne steht mit einem
bekannten sich zu verabreden dass
draußen zu gehen in die natur um aktiv
zu bleiben das empfehlen wir alle
häufigsten aber auch in kontakt zu
bleiben eben durch telefonate oder video
kontakte
das wird das brauchen wir menschen sind
soziale wesen wir brauchen das
miteinander wir brauchen auch den
austausch
ich gucke in den austausch in unseren
chat müssen jetzt auch ein bisschen
darum bitten das wird aber auch
freundlich und und zivil miteinander
bleiben also es gibt einige die immer
noch meinen also das hätte alles mit den
maßnahmen zu tun und ohne die korona
schutzmaßnahmen wird uns allen besser
gehen das haben wir gerade schon mit
frau doktor köhler gesprochen dass das
nicht unbedingt so der fall ist jetzt
gibt es aber auch eine frage an sie herr
münchen nämlich wie hat sich ihr leben
geändert
was ist jetzt was ist jetzt anders und
auch die seite die therapie aus oder
sieht die therapie aus die sie gerade
machen
aktuell bin ich schon wieder in der
wiedereingliederung
davor war ich in der tagesklinik in
bingen und jetzt fragen sie die frage
nochmal würde
wie hat sich ihr leben quasi geändert
jetzt auch in den letzten wochen bei mir
hat sich einiges geändert ich bin
ruhiger geworden
ich gehe gewisse sachen langsam mehr an
ich nehme schrieb schon mehr direkt auf
100 prozent
auch so diesen perfektionist den ich
stark in mir hatte bin ich am ablegen
was auch nicht so einfach ist ich
versuche mir das beste daraus zu machen
und was für was für therapieform wurden
mit ihnen gemacht da gibt es ja durchaus
verschiedene es gibt das
die kommentar es gibt verhaltenstherapie
es gibt so etwas wie maltherapie
gesprächstherapie was war das bei ihnen
genau und ich waren der
verhaltenstherapie auch kognitives
training gruppen offene themen
repressions beteiligungsgruppe angst
gruppe ist volle programm war das bei
mir und das hat ihnen letztendlich
geholfen
wie man sieht das ist ja schön zu sehen
wie kann man dann entscheiden welche
therapieformen für einen das beste ist
an welchen facharzt oder an welche
psychotherapeutin psychotherapeuten man
sich wendet das ist ja auch schon wieder
ein großer dschungel und viele
möglichkeiten die man hat also man
sollte wenn tatsächlich eine krankheit
vorliegt und das wird ja ein hausarzt
facharzt oder psychotherapie die
akquisition können
zunächst einmal das gesamte spektrum
spektrum an behandlungsmöglichkeiten
überlegen und dann sind da gute
ansprechpartner die fachärzte für
psychiatrie psychotherapie die
nervenärzte die bereits wird soma tische
mit ziehen und auch die
psychotherapeutin die zumindest
grundkenntnisse auch in der
medikamentenversorgung haben aber so
einen allgemeinen überblick und die
kompetenzen im medizinischen und
psychotherapeutischen bereich haben eben
die fachärzte und ich empfehle immer das
gesamtspektrum zu beginn einer möglichen
behandlung in den blick zu nehmen
sie spreche dann mit meinen patienten
die diagnose und stelle alle
behandlungsmöglichkeiten vor und
entscheidet dann gemeinsam mit dem
patienten welche therapie und welche
verschiedenen therapieformen sie hatten
herr münchner auch erzählt dass sie
verschiedene formen der therapie in
anspruch genommen haben welche hier
sinnvoll sein können und welche
kombinationen eingesetzt werden und das
wird im rahmen der behandlungen im laufe
der behandlungstage und wochen immer
wieder angepasst und überlegt welche
behandlung macht die sind häufig ist das
so dass wir mit einer medikamentösen
therapie beginnen um den passieren
jürgen schnell aus diesem tiefen tief
herauszubringen und ihn auch in die lage
zu versetzen diese komplexen vorgänge
die dann in der psychotherapeutischen
also eine gesprächstherapie stadt sind
anzunehmen und das also gut aufzunehmen
und damit zu arbeiten
die medikamentöse therapie wird aber
auch von manchen patienten gar nicht
gewünscht da gibt es bei vielen sehr
große vorbehalte
dann versuchen wir also auch mit anderen
methoden mit mit psychotherapeuten
benzin mit anderen entlastungs formen da
zu helfen und nicht selten ist es so
dass patienten die sich das dann auch
eine weile überlegen dann zu mir kommen
und sagen ich probiere es jetzt doch
noch medikament vielleicht um besser
schlafen nicht mehr so angespannt zu
sein und dann klappt es auch mit der
psychotherapie ganz gut also dass das
ist groß es gibt ein großes angebot an
hilfsmaßnahmen und man sollte dann ganz
individuell kochen was kann der patient
selber akzeptieren und was ist hier
aufgrund der diagnose und der schwere
der erkrankung empfehlen sie hat durch
den arzt wenn man mich haben sie auch
mit medikamenten angefangen ich hab sie
da glaube ich nicht gesehen
ich bekomme auch medikamente morgens und
abends
und wie wirkt sich das bei ihnen aus ich
kann dazu was sagen und zwar sehr gut
ich habe anfangs in der fachklinik
wodurch auch ein medikament eingestellt
auch mit dem medikament entlassen wenn
der tag training haben wir versucht das
medikament auszugleichen und umzustellen
was nach hinten los ging das kam zu
einem rückfall somit dass ich dann
wieder auf die alten medikamente
gegangen bin und die jetzt auch weiter
entgegen vieler viele patientinnen haben
ja angst frau dr köhler dass sie dann
abhängig werden oder ist es auch zu
starken nebenwirkungen kommt was können
sie denn dazu sagen nicht abhängig
machen
es gibt medikamente nicht dauerhaft
eingesetzt wie setze ich fast nie ein
sondern ich versuche das optimale
antidepressivum
zu finden für den patienten und dann
kann man sagen es gibt kein
antidepressivum was in der abhängigkeit
führt das ist der diskussion die ich
eigentlich mit fast jedem patienten der
zuerst einmal zu bekommen führe weil da
gibt es viel unwissen
aber dafür sind wir ja da dafür sind wir
da das zu erklären und da auch die
ängste ein stück weit zu nehmen und wie
wird denn wenn wir dann so ein erfolg
haben wie bei ihnen herr münch dass das
gut hilft und dass sie merken dass ihnen
wissen dass ein patient mit einem
medikament gut in der lage ist sein
leben wieder in den griff zu bekommen
dann sind die patienten durchaus auch
dankbar und eine medikamentöse
behandlung in den meisten fällen nicht
dauerhaft lebenslang notwendig so wie
wir das wenn wir über diabetes oder
bluthochdruck reden
doch häufig in den blick nehmen müssen
sondern antidepressiva sind für
bestimmte lebensphasen häufig wichtig
und bei fast allen patienten überlegen
war im laufe der zeit ob das medikament
wieder abgesetzt ausgeschlossen werden
kann
und auch das wird gemeinsam mit dem
patienten besprochen letzten endes ist
der patient derjenige der über seine
behandlung bestimmt herr münch das gibt
es einige fragen hier wie man ihnen
folgen kann zum beispiel auf facebook
können sie da mal die seite sagen dann
tippe ich die zum beispiel bei youtube
gleich mal in die kommentare
genau das ist meine depression und der
weg zum ziel
alles aufgeschrieben in einem wort
auseinander ganz normal - dazwischen
oder mit punkt also der alle zusammen
geschrieben und meinem eine depression
und der weg zum ziel
okay das und der weg zum ziel und hoffe
ich mal dass ich jetzt kein fehler hier
gemacht hat ich habe das mal bei uns in
die youtube kommentare geschrieben
können die kolleginnen fragen was ist
auch bei facebook einmal verlinken dann
findet ihr dort herrn münchen könnt euch
mit ihm austauschen
jetzt eine kurze frage noch frau dr
kühler
so viel zeit haben nicht nur noch
einzugehen aber es gibt jedoch immer
wieder die beschwerden dass es zu wenig
ärztinnen und ärzte gibt zu wenig
psychotherapie plätze dass es zu langen
wartelisten und lange wartezeiten kommt
ich kann euch dazu auch die zdfzoom doku
empfehlen die wir dazu letzte woche
hatten wir haben auch auf youtube einen
film dazu dem wir euch gleich noch
verlinken aber vielleicht können sie das
trotzdem noch mal ganz kurz was dazu
sagen wie es dazu kommt dass wir im
endeffekt ein land mit einer großen
krankenkassensystem in große
medizinsystem sind und trotzdem menschen
darauf warten müssen dass sie hilfe
bekommen
naja also diese hilfe ist für jeden
uneingeschränkt möglich und das ist
genau das was das problem zum wachsen
bringt das nämlich auch
psychotherapeutische behandlungen in
deutschland im gegensatz zu vielen
anderen ländern in europa sogar
konsequent durch die gesetzliche
krankenkasse bezahlt wird in einen
bestimmten kontingents also jeder hat
darauf anspruch muss es nicht selbst
bezahlen und damit ist die hürde solche
behandlung in anspruch zu nehmen sehr
gering und viele patienten wünschen sich
diese eins zu eins betreuung im
intensiven gespräch
obwohl haben es genau diese
stigmatisierung gibt dass menschen
irgendwie eine scheu haben so einen
therapeuten deutschen psychiater hat zum
thema die stigmatisierung ist in bezug
auf die psychotherapeutin viel geringer
als im zug auf die ärzte also als bezug
auf die psychiater also die psychiater
sind ja auch psychotherapeuten
aber der begriff psychiater ist offenbar
immer noch einen schreck begriff im
gegensatz zu dem des psychotherapeuten
psychotherapeuten können ja auch
psychologen seien die diese ausbildung
gemacht haben und die dann keine achse
sind die keine medikamente verordnet die
auch nicht in kliniken quasi
zwangsmaßnahmen anwenden dürfen die in
manchen fällen ja tatsächlich notwendig
sind für besonders schwer kranke aber
das macht unsere dem den blick auf
unsere berufsgruppe ein bisschen
schwierig und diese therapieplätze sind
deshalb weil die nachfrage so groß ist
natürlich begrenzt weil die
krankenkassen nur eine bestimmte anzahl
an
therapeuten finanzieren können mit
erholung bei beiträgen mit ihren
beiträgen also sind wir mehr therapeuten
im land haben wollen oder haben müssen
würden glaube ich die krankenkassen ihre
beiträge erhöhen und das kann im moment
auch keiner wollen
also das ist ein finanzierungsproblem
was wir in deutschland haben
es ist außerdem so dass wenn mehr gucken
psychotherapien stattfinden würden also
wenn ein therapeut fünf oder sechs
patienten gleichzeitig in einer gruppe
behandelt sowie das in kliniken oft der
fall ist
wir ja deutlich mehr patienten versorgen
könnten das ist allerdings nur selten
der fall also es gibt die möglichkeit
gruppenpsychotherapie durchzuführen aber
es gibt wenig angebote im land im moment
dafür es ist gerade am wachsen weil die
bedingungen dafür sich verändert habe
aber das ist ja auch in corona
bedingungen schwierig gerade so sind wie
bist du denn es ist schwierig genau und
man muss sich darüber einigen ob man das
auch in so einer vbw hier zusammensitzen
als kleine gruppe möglich macht aber die
dieses defizit an therapieplätzen gab es
ja auch schon vor corona und das ist ein
grund dafür es gibt noch viele andere
gründe warum das so schwierig ist aber
das ist ein grund dafür
ich will noch mal in die kommentare hier
ich habe einige zuschauer immer die
sagen auch vorsicht im umgang mit
psychopharmaka ich habe bei mir einer
nahestehenden person erlebt dies im
zusammenhang mit alkohol zu
fehleinschätzungen der gesamten
lebenssituation kam das ist natürlich
auch eine sache die sollte besser nicht
passieren aber passiert natürlich
teilweise andere schreiben hier
ich hatte das glück direkt zum anfang
der pandemie einen therapieplatz zu
bekommen hatte dann noch sorge dass als
alleinerziehende mit vorgeschichte ich
das ganze nicht meistern hürde also wir
haben hier durchaus verschiedene
einschätzungen zu dem ganzen ich würde
mich jetzt noch mal interessieren frau
dr köder was kann ich denn jetzt tun
also auch wenn ich merke ich brauche
hilfe ich krieg sie nicht sofort
vielleicht auch weil jetzt die klinik
plätze voll sind oder weil die
psychotherapie wartelisten lang sind
was kann ich jetzt akut machen
also zum einen gibt es ja verschiedene
beratungsangebote die unterhalb der
mediziner psychotherapeuten
versorgungsform sich bewegen
telefonseelsorger beratungsstellen bei
gesundheitsämtern
familienberatungsstellen und so weiter
also oder für studenten nicht willkommen
aus einer studentenstadt da gibt es eine
psychosoziale beratungsstelle für
studenten in lebenskrisen beispielsweise
die sind gute ansprechpartner und
geschult auch im umgang und mit dem
diagnostischen blick ist das jetzt der
lebenskrise die man bewältigen karten
blicken beratung oder ist das eine krise
die spezielle therapeutische
intervention braucht diese
beratungsstellen sind zunächst erstmal
ansprechpartner dann gibt es eigentlich
für jeden menschen die möglichkeit sich
an einen hausarzt zu wenden und die
hausärzte sind ja auch ausgebildet in
der ersten diagnostik von solchen
psychischen krisen die meisten hausärzte
haben kontakte auch zu den
entsprechenden fachärztlichen
psychotherapeutischen fachkollegen in
ihrer stadt in ihrem landkreis in ihrer
umgebung und können eventuell der
termine vermitteln und darüber hinaus
gibt es ja seit einiger zeit die so
genannten termin servicestellen bei
allen kassenärztlichen vereinigungen im
bundesland über die 11 6 11 7 können
patienten dort termine zur erstberatung
oder zu einem erstgespräch oder zu einer
fachärztlichen einschätzung vereinbaren
und es gibt natürlich dann die
verpflichtung für den facharzt für den
psychotherapeuten wenn der akuten
handlungsbedarf sieht auch akku zu
handeln wenn sich dann herausstellt dass
der behandlungsbedarf besteht aber nicht
akut hand gehandelt werden muss gibt es
eigentlich an so einer stelle auch immer
eine beratung wie die geschichte weiter
geführt werden kann also wie weitere
diagnostik oder weiterer behandlung
gebannt werden kann wenn es nicht so
hoch akut ist aber eben trotzdem
notwendig wie ist das bei ihnen weiter
herr münch geschwister zeit in der
wiedereingliederung in der stufenweisen
das heißt jetzt erstmal zwei stunden
dann wird gesteigert auf 3 4 6 und 8
alles meinem
was sage ich mal wenn ich dem arzt das
ok gebe dass ich der belastung schon
wieder gewachsen bin
dann wird das gesteigert und das ist der
aktuelle plan bei mir ja das heißt sie
sind optimistisch dass es im laufe des
jahres bergauf geht ich sage es mal so
ich tue alles dafür dass es bergauf geht
natürlich auch mit vorsicht
aber ich bin guter dinge dann wünsche
ich ihnen sehr viel erfolg gute
besserung und dass es bald wieder in die
gewohnte bahnen geht ich danke ihnen für
ihre offenheit dass sie heute bei uns
gewesen sind auch in frau doktor köhler
für ihre ansichten und die erklärungen
und bei euch bedanke ich mich fürs
kommentieren und für fragen und fürs
zuschauen wie immer
wir sind mit sicherheit morgen wieder
die darf ihr euch dann mit einem neuen
thema und einem neuen leisten auch wenn
uns die korona krisen mit sicherheit
noch nicht ganz so weiter begleiten wird
bei zdf heute.de seite gut informiert
ihr könnt ihr euch die app ziehen dann
kriegt ihr immer der push mitteilungen
wir online gehen oder abonniert doch den
kanal hier und macht die bim bankdrücker
an dann kriegt er immer sofort eine
meldung wenn wir online gehen aber er
zerrissen auf vielen dank bis zum
nächsten mal macht gut und tschüss